mine sweeping in Croatia 20 years after
the Yugoslav wars the tiny southeastern
European state is about to become a
member of the European Union but much of
the country still looks like this
Croatia will be the first GU country to
have experienced a war in the lifetime
of the EU
my journey begins in Zagreb the Croatian
capital looks much like other European
cities in the 1990s I often reported
from here during the Croatian struggle
for independence in the Yugoslav wars
now almost 20 years later I want to find
out how it has changed a new young
post-war generation has grown up I meet
up with Borner Matco Daniel Jeffrey and
Luka they're all around nineteen years
old and they're all musicians they're
hardrock band is called we create by
which they mean their own reality Borna
thinks it's a good thing that croatia is
finally joining the EU because we are we
going to do so we I'm not for entering
for Croatia to enter the European Union
and because I mean the price will go up
and the paycheck will stay the same for
sale a group of activists has put up
posters like this one on national
monuments all over Zagreb they fear
their country is about to be sold off
mainly to investors from the EU by a
company that five band members to a gig
in the countryside far away from the
glamour of the capital Zagreb we take
the motorway recently built and easily
up to the standards of Western European
roads we're heading south to a place
called Carla vats where the band are due
to play at a music festival this was a
frontline town in the war that took
place during the 1990s right from the
outbreak the residents of Carla vats
came under regular serbian artillery
fire a lot of the damage is still not
repaired the young Zagreb musicians were
only just born then
whoa let's go these young men only know
about the war between Serbia and their
own country Croatia from history books
it's not real easy to see you know
everything what was happening like 18
years ago and you know about what can I
say now everything is ok that's that's
the main thing yeah so and I really
think that it's going to be ok for the
next I know forever they have quite
different concerns such as whether
they'll be able to earn a living from
their music when born er Luka and the
others think about their future after
graduation it doesn't look too good
more than 40 percent of young Croatians
are unemployed something they have in
common with many other young Europeans
Boehner says without work experience you
can't even get an entry-level job when
we finish college no one wants us a lot
of companies employ people who've been
with them for twenty thirty years
already they retire but keep on working
for less money the companies exploit
them and we are completely forgotten
about
at least they've got their music but
even during the soundcheck there's
trouble a neighbor comes to complain
about the noise
it seems to me that conflict between the
War generation and the post-war
generation are routine in Croatia to see
how many traces of the war in the 1990s
are left I take a drive along the former
front line between Croatia and Serbia
abandoned villages desolate landscapes
in eastern Croatian Slavonia before the
wall it was mostly Serbs who lived here
after the Croatian army liberated the
occupied region thousands of Serbs fled
there are a lot of houses for sale
economically this region is yet to
recover from the war there is very
little work available the jobs of Marco
pizu llyich and his colleagues are safe
but also extremely dangerous there
minesweepers we drive to a small town
called Ratko vats serbian troops were
stationed nearby during the war and they
mined the nearby woods Marko and his
team are here to clear the mines a
laborious task you can see here what
we've done already the square meters we
did yesterday says Marko
today we'll move on to this area
everyone has to sign for the area
they're checked for mines our signatures
guarantee that an area is supposed to be
safe that's just 20 square metres per
person per day
this armored minesweeper is only
available to help sometimes step-by-step
marco covers the designated area for
salaam just a piece of metal not a mine
fear he asks of course I'm nervous when
I'm standing in the minefield
but he says apart from minesweeping he
has few other options I was a soldier
myself during the war he says and
afterwards there was no work for me this
was the only chance for work I had it's
been like this for ten years and at this
stage I don't even think about doing
anything else he plans to continue
searching for mines until he retires and
hopes he doesn't get blown up Steve and
Chris Nick is the team leader he was
also in the croatian army they planted
mines just like their serve enemies and
occasionally he's even had to clear away
his own mines
he has no illusions I started doing this
work in 1996 he says the plan then was
to clear the whole country of mines by
2010 in 2010 they said it would take
until 2015 now the government says it
will be in 2019 but no one here believes
that it could take 20 or 30 years they
say because Croatia doesn't have the
money to finance the work
Romano meanie mother dear we are a
monthly minimum of three hundred and
eighty five euros says Sandra Jankovic
that goes up to twelve hundred euros if
the company has an actual contract but
that's the problem
the government doesn't allocate enough
money for mine clearing the budget is
too small and there's certainly enough
work for us to do Sandra Yankovic is one
of only two female minesweepers in
Croatia she'd rather do the dangerous
work than be without a job the mine
sweepers hoped that when Croatia joins
the EU more money will be made available
from Brussels the mines are preventing
economic development especially in the
forestry sector Marko shift lasts for
five hours it's not possible to
concentrate safely for any longer than
that they haven't found any mines today
but at least they've made a few more
square metres safe you can't guarantee a
hundred percent safety says Marko 90 or
95 yes but not 100 percent it's not
possible
it's the forestry workers and farmers
who face the remaining risk but I don't
think that's the only reason for the
lack of progress here in the poorer
parts of Eastern Croatia near the forest
where the mine sweepers are working I
meet Sveta Barbic he's an official
representative for the minority rights
of the remaining Serbs still living in
the region most of his relatives didn't
return after the war my uncle built that
old yellow house there he says this one
belongs to my brother this is where my
father was born it all belongs to the
bar [ __ ] family but he's the only
family member still living here
Sveta wants to sell the other properties
but there's a problem it's here
somewhere
the pipe leads into the septic tank he
says but it's been covered over well
under here is the sewage pit her
neighbor built it illegally on my land
but the well is right here he says his
Croatian neighbor didn't care about his
property rights because his a Serbs
Vader says but with the neighbors slurry
pit right next to the well no one wants
to buy the property I've reported it to
the authorities but there was no
reaction that was a few years ago maybe
the time wasn't right
Sveta Babbage points to another Croatian
neighbor with whom he's on friendly
terms he'd like to buy the property but
without the sewage pit under the grass a
neighbor urges fatal Babbage to go to
court over the issue these two at least
get on well money for a case Babbage
says if I go to court I'd need several
thousand euros and it would take a long
time only people with a lot of money can
afford to sue these days
you know what but you never cry legal
costs in Croatia are more expensive than
in Germany court cases last four years
the EU has been calling for improvements
to the justice system for years
partially also as a way of dealing more
effectively with inter-ethnic hatred but
there has been much progress in rural
areas Croatia is about to join the EU
but my journey has shown me that the
country is still suffering from the
effects of the war even if things look
differently back in Zagreb a capital
that is the equal of many other European
cities